it's about 7:30 a.m. just put the spikes
on headed up to the base of the load C
face and we're gonna work our way up
today
okay put helmets on and it really rears
up now for another 2,000 feet to camp
three
we have a lot of work to do when we
arrive to what we think would be a good
site the uphill side of the camp we've
got to chop the snow we've got a big big
blocks and push it all to the downhill
side so it's kind of cut and fill cut
and fill until we've got a platform big
enough to place three or four of our
tents here at Camp three it's like a
little weather might be moving in here
just in the last ten or so we flied out
a little bit of snow there's our third
tent got one more to go
should be looking good here and
hopefully be able to tuck into things
deteriorate up here at 23,000 400 feet
at camp three and just have been here
for a few hours and can start to feel
the altitude trying to drink and keep
making snow into water and that's gonna
be the name of the game for the next two
days you've been working on this first
ascent clothing well over a year indoors
and meetings with designers back and
forth this and that and finally for the
first time right now right here I'm in
this suit and enjoying it up here what
we really needed this is the moment
you